hi
this is dr gregory sadler i'm a
professor of philosophy and the
president and founder of an educational
consulting company called reason i o
where we put philosophy into practice
i've studied and taught philosophy for
over 20 years and i find that many
people run into difficulties reading
classic philosophical texts
sometimes it's the way things are said
or how the text is structured
but the concepts themselves are not
always that complicated and that's where
i come in
to help students and lifelong learners
i've been producing longer lecture
videos and posting them to youtube
many viewers say they find them useful
what you're currently watching is part
of a new series of shorter videos each
of them focused on one core concept from
an important philosophical text i hope
you find it useful as well
robert audi in his article
virtue ethics as a resource in business
towards the end is going to talk about
five contexts for using virtue ethics
and indeed virtue ethics or artic
concepts in business ethics but also
more broadly speaking because it's good
to remember
that business is not the only domain of
a business person's life right so virtue
ethics would help to address uh other
aspects other domains of life and help
one to become a more integrated person
when we're talking about virtue ethic
concepts these include the virtues and
also their opposites the vices and these
can be quite helpful for thinking about
moral reasoning decision making and
development in a number of different
ways
so
one that's particularly basic is what we
can call the context of
aspiration and he says
one question that we can ask and people
do ask this very often in the course of
their life is what kind of a person do i
want to be what kind of person do i
really
want to be
do i want to be the kind of person who
actually has good moral qualities or do
i want to be the kind of person who
fakes it and gets away with stuff and
then has to look at themselves in the
proverbial mirror later on who always
has to be a bit worried about other
people
finding out that they're they're fraud
in in moral terms or you know maybe
they're not bothered by that in which
case they can say i just want to be
ruthless in which case they may not have
that much connection with virtue ethics
but it can still be useful to clarify
for themselves that they're not going to
have much to do with any sort of ethics
really when it comes down to it most
people if you ask them what kind of
person do they want to be there's going
to be a disconnect between the person
that they know themselves to be at this
point in time and the person that they'd
like themselves to be and they don't
usually unless they're you know a bit
misguided bring up vices like saying i
want to be a more unjust person i want
to be a less
generous person a more stingy person or
a more uh spendthrift person they
usually say things like well i want to
be you know more well integrated i want
to be more diligent i want to improve my
work ethic i want to be more just with
with other people more fair more honest
and so
the the virtues can help to clarify for
us what kind of people we want to be and
also what kind of people we want other
people to be if we say what kind of
leaders do we want or what kind of
workers do we want or what kind of
people on our own level peers co-workers
do we want to have we often will use
virtue terms for that so that's that's
one thing and this leads quite naturally
into what he calls the context of
prohibition meaning saying don't be like
this kind of person don't be a bad
person in these respects and so you know
actually i'm going to read this is a
great line he says
the power of pejoratives is not to be
understood underestimated especially in
their noun forms in which their
application suggests a vice or serious
defect of character it is at best a rare
person who does not have a deep aversion
to be being called things like liar
cheat coward brute bully thief turn coat
fraud or phony some of these are a
little old-fashioned right
audi is is uh writing this quite a while
back
we can come up with lots of other things
inauthentic right
a grifter and he says such labels are
generally rejected even by such
offenders as the perpetrators of the
enron and worldcom
scandals even they
didn't want people saying bad stuff
about them as a matter of fact they'd
often retaliate or be very defensive and
try to justify their clearly immoral
behavior because they didn't want to be
called that sort of stuff now it's one
thing just to call people names it's
another thing to do so in a way where
you say
this actually sticks you have this vice
this is part of what's wrong with you
this is part of what's bad about the
corporate culture you developed so
clarifying these negative terms what is
it to be a greedy person what is it to
be
a dishonest person right what is it to
be a cheat
these are things that virtue ethics can
help us clarify
then we have uh correlative to this the
context of exhortation he says nearly
everyone wants to be considered honest
fair loyal just sincere kind generous
these sorts of things these should be
developed in moral education and some of
these figure into major moral principles
and so you know they're appropriate for
uh like he says teaching ethics
critically appraising actions leading
employees they're also appropriate to
institutional mission statements
although oftentimes mission statements
are a little bit bland and
underdeveloped in this respect
so we can we can clarify and advocate
what positive traits we think a person
ought to have
somebody might answer the question what
kind of person do you want to be what
excellences should you have and leave
some out and then we can say well you
know this is really good you're working
on the honesty part
i'd like you also maybe in a coaching
session we say this i'd like you also to
work on the diligence part like actually
following through or perseverance
sticking to a task and going all the way
to the end it's really nice that you
have great ideas it's really nice to get
along with your co-workers this is an
area that we'd like to see you working
on and so we exhort we urge people to
develop these these areas
then we have the context of what he
calls discovery and he says we can
reflect on what it is to have a given
virtue we can ask of various role models
who have a virtue have acted or would
have acted we can look to narratives
historical or fictional
all of these are modes of discovery
figuring out
what the virtue actually looks like or
we can also say looking
what does the vice look like or what
does it look like to be a person who
lacks character
and kind of wavers between virtues and
vices as well those are all helped out
by looking not just to abstract concepts
of virtue but to places where virtues
are displayed and talked about and
depicted
so he says that all of these help us to
decide what kind of person we want to be
or less broadly what kind of business
person we want to be
then finally we have the context of what
he calls justification
and this doesn't mean just like sort of
justifying yourself in a defensive way
this means explaining the actions that
somebody is engaged in to say they they
actually are doing
virtuous actions actions either in
accordance with virtue or action
stemming from virtue uh from a
disposition that one has actually
developed within oneself or
correlatively vicious actions you know
this is a bad action because it's a
greedy action person isn't actually a
greedy person but they have decided to
act like a greedy person in this context
we want to be able to say
and explain
how that's the case and this is going to
as he points out involved involve
combining moral and non-moral concepts
oftentimes bringing up relevant and
specific facts
so you know he says when it comes to
justifying moral judgments and moral
decisions
virtue ethical statements like it was
the just solution and loyalty to man
standing by her even though she made the
wrong decision have a kind of
incompleteness we need to know what else
to add in there in order to provide an
explanation or justification and so we
use these virtue terms and concepts
which should correspond to realities
that we experience and develop within
ourselves hopefully the virtuous ones
not the vicious ones
we use these in all of these different
contexts to engage in moral
decision-making within
life contexts but also within business
contexts as well and so virtue ethics
offers
resources for doing this well within
business contexts and situations
you